[Musique]
Véronique prince Michel c'est AUG
Jonathan Trudeau bonsoir
bonsoir
transfert en santé est-ce qu'on avance
est-ce qu'on fait du surplace est-ce que
il y a une rencontre vendredi matin
monsieur Trudeau et monsieur Legault on
écoute quelques extraits de la journée
pour revenir
les provinces vont rouler sur des
déficits puis le fédéral va avoir des
grosses surplus parce qu'on c'est la
seule dépense la dépense de santé qui
augmente de 5-6% puis là je parle des
années où il y a pas d'inflation
anormales sa seule dépense
on a besoin d'améliorer nos systèmes de
santé le rôle le gouvernement fédéral un
rôle à jouer absolument mais on
reconnaît le lait de Chypre des
provinces en matière de santé ils vont
continuer de le faire
quand en 2022 on utilise encore des sacs
et des bouts de papier pour transmettre
des informations sur la santé des gens
on n'est pas à la hauteur des besoins du
Canada heureusement on peut faire mieux
et beaucoup mieux rapidement et c'est ce
qu'on a convenu de faire en privé avant
courant mais il faut que les premiers
ministres nous laissent faire notre
travail et communiste à santé donc nous
obliger à ne pas parler de résultats
mais à focaliser entièrement sur les
dollars ce n'est malheureusement pas un
plan en santé
nous parler juste d'argent puis parce
que nous on veut discuter avec les
provinces de quoi de
seuil de baisse de liste d'attente de
manière
des conditions oui exactement et pour le
commun des mortel en fait lorsque ces
gens-là les gens qui nous écoutent
regardent ces extraits là on a
l'impression effectivement que sa
piétine et pendant que ce bras faire là
cette ternise mais les gens attendent à
l'urgence ils ont de la difficulté avant
leur médecin de famille leur chirurgie
dans certains cas sont reportés sont
retardés et il y a probablement le
gouvernement Trudeau qui mis sur cette
pression peut-être il va venir de
l'opinion publique parce que quand les
gens sont mécontents de leur réseau de
santé c'est pour gouvernement Trudeau
qui va aller le dire sous le
gouvernement le goût c'est Christian
Dubé qui va entendre les doléances des
gens et je peux supposer peut-être que
partout dans les provinces c'est comme
ça que le fédéral mise là-dessus c'est à
dire que l'opinion publique va peut-être
finir par mener à l'effritement du front
commun peut-être que c'est la stratégie
qu'ils envisagent et à ce moment-là eux
pourront arriver puis dire à regarder
nous on va y aller avec des normes
nationales et on va réussir là où les
provinces sont incapables de réussir
donc je me dis est-ce que c'est ça la
stratégie en ce moment
ça avance à petit pas parce qu'il y a eu
une rencontre à Vancouver monsieur
Duclos fait référence à cette rencontre
mais on a l'impression que ça tourne un
peu en rond et là les peut-être les
vrais discussions commencent là je
parlais du tête-à-tête Trudeau le goût
vendredi matin
vous me permettrez de pas être très
optimiste là-dessus vous savez Patrick
je suis arrivé la tribune de la presse
en 1977 et on avait exactement le même
débat le gouvernement fédéral qui disait
faux des normes fédérales nous on va
donner plus d'argent c'est sûr mais il
va falloir que bon s'arrête les faxs les
hôpitaux déjà à ce moment-là alors un
moment donné que l'on soit rendu
maintenant que ça dise encore la même
chose l'obsession fédérale de dire il
faut que les provinces nous donnent des
informations pourquoi ils veulent les
informations pour faire des normes
fédérales voici le gouvernement qui ne
gère pas seul hôpital qui jamais ne plus
hôpitaux d'anciens combattants ils ont
redonné aux provinces parce qu'ils
voulaient pas puis qui la seule façon de
savoir c'est quoi le prix d'une boîte de
tillénon c'est d'envoyer quelque chose
qui va donner des des ordres ça a pas de
bon sens mais Michel je vais continuer
une seconde avant Jonathan le sous-tex
de ce que le gouvernement fédéral dit
c'est de dire on veut pas rajouter de
l'argent dans un système qui marche pas
donc prouvé nous que ça va marcher c'est
ça le sous-tex
à ce moment-là
les fax pourquoi ils sont là ils sont
plus là mais je sais pourquoi ils ont
été trop longtemps parce qu'on avait pas
d'argent pour acheter un système
informatique parce qu'on est impatiente
c'est bien normal alors un moment donné
là il va falloir que le principe du
gouvernement fédéral qui d'Ottawa c'est
tout et va contrôler les les hôpitaux ça
arrête d'être mentionné parce que c'est
ça qui fait
dérailler chacune des rôles de
négociation parce que Jonathan encore
aujourd'hui ou hier monsieur Trudeau a
dit c'est pas de chèques en blanc il
reviennent avec cette position en fait
ils ont jamais changé de position en
fait absolument il y a à chaque fois
qu'on a l'impression qu'on fait un petit
pas par en avant on a l'impression par
la suite qu'on en fait deux en arrière
alors la première rencontre un peu plus
informelle au sommet de la Francophonie
entre François Legault et Justin Trudeau
on a vu l'impression que
il y avait certaines bases sur le
partage des données un peu d'ouverture
la peur de François Legault Justin
Trudeau qui lui démontré l'ouverture
pour augmenter les transferts et là
quand j'ai lu les propos rapportés de
Justin Trudeau hier même chose du côté
de Jean-Yves Duclos on a l'impression
finalement on est on est revenu en
arrière mais moi je veux bien là qui est
un face à face que il y a une
négociation puisqu'on nous dise qu'un
coulisse le dialogue est plus souvent et
tout ça mais encore faut-il que les
intervenants soient crédibles lorsqu'ils
ont des positions qui sont campées sur
leur position et vraiment l'entendre du
Clos d'entendre du centre d'eau faire la
leçon aux provinces quand on pense au
système de paye Phoenix là est-ce qu'on
est capable de payer nos employés aux
deux semaines avant de faire la leçon
aux provinces sur comment gérer le
système de santé est-ce qu'on est
responsable de délivrer des passeports
dans des délais raisonnables traiter des
dossiers des demandes d'immigration dans
des délais acceptables le fédéral n'a
pas de leçon à donner aux provinces moi
je veux bien qu'ils disent on souhaite
que les provinces et un plan mais tant
mieux le Québec il a un plat peut-être
pas parfait mais Christelle Dubé il veut
pas juste lancer l'argent par les
fenêtres ce qui serait important ça sera
le pignon public Véronique en parlait
est-ce que vous croyez que le
gouvernement fédéral des appuis ou de
plus en plus en fait où la population
des provinces appuie d'après vous en
majorité leur gouvernement provinciaux
Véronique mais en fait c'est ça comme je
vous le disais les plaintes elles vont
pas être acheminées au gouvernement
fédéral donc est-ce qu'un moment donné
une province je dis pas que ça va être
le Québec là mais ce qui a un province à
un moment donné qui fasse à ce
mécontentement de la population va finir
peut-être par y aller avec une
négociation de coulisses parce que c'est
souvent ce qui arrive dans des
situations comme ça c'est qu'il y a une
deux trois provinces qui finalement
négocient en coulisses de son côté ça
brise le front commun et c'est à ce
moment-là que le fédéral peut profiter
de cette fenêtre là par contre moi ce
que je remarque cette semaine mes
collègues sont peut-être pas d'accord
avec moi mais je trouve que le temps
plus
assez plus Acer plus provoquant a l'air
de venir d'Ottawa davantage que les
provinces alors que dans les derniers
mois c'était François Legault qui
consentait beaucoup plus ulcéré par
Monsieur Trudeau on le sentait plus
provoquant puis encore aujourd'hui au
point de presse on avait l'impression
qu'il nous convoquait justement pour
envoyer des messages à Justin Trudeau à
24 heures de sa rencontre avec lui donc
on se disait par média interposés
probablement qui veut réagir quand même
assez fort sur un deux trois enjeux mais
le ton était quand même relativement
calme là parce qu'on me dit c'est la
première rencontre en personne c'est pas
nécessairement le temps d'envoyer des
coups de poing tout de suite
d'ailleurs l'autre gros sujet ça sera
l'immigrations monsieur LEGO a changé un
peu ces demandes en tout cas on parle
moins si le pas changé de rapatrier tous
les pouvoirs là c'est davantage miser
sur l'immigration francophone on écoute
monsieur Legault et monsieur mon écoute
sur le groupe
on sait que sur les 50 000 qui sont
acceptés il y en a 60% qui sont choisis
par le Québec 40% par
Ottawa dans ceux qui sont choisis par
Ottawa il y en a seulement la moitié qui
parle français
quand monsieur Trudeau dit on pourrait
en avoir
112000 qui parle français mais
commençons par le 40% là j'ai des doutes
qu'on est capable de tous les avoir pas
français
le faut comprendre puis là on va
remettre
le son puis nous lui raconterait tout ça
en forte détail mais Michel C le 40%
dont on parle monsieur Legault c'est la
réunification familiale et les réfugiés
qui sont les deux autres catégories
Québec à 100% de l'autorité sur la
partie économique des migration bon
l'immigration temporaire ça c'est le
fédéral aussi alors bref mais on a
l'impression que les demandes de Québec
sont pas si claires Michel
ils reviennent toujours avec des choses
qui ne sont pas complètement exacte
c'est vrai que la moitié des demandes en
réunification familiale sont déjà qui
parlent pas français mais allez-vous
interdire à une mère de venir rejoindre
ses enfants
à la fin la réunification familiale
c'est quelque chose d'humanitaire c'est
pas quelque chose d'économique alors
on peut y penser que comme il y a
beaucoup d'enfants là-dedans grand
nombre ils vont l'apprendre à l'école vu
que la loi sert s'applique est-ce qu'on
va interdire à une grand-mère qui sera
jamais sur le marché du travail devenir
penser ces vieux jours au Québec et
garder les enfants puis tout ça c'est
des choses comme ça alors quand Monsieur
le goût dit donne la statistique ça a
l'air bien grave dans la réalité des
choses ça les réfugiés cette histoire-là
bon Jonathan qu'est-ce que vous
comprenez aujourd'hui le 17h46 de la
position du Québec face à de quoi
qu'est-ce qui va demander précisément
monsieur Trudeau vendredi sur
l'immigration
moi j'ai l'impression que il va marteler
l'importance d'aller chercher là c'est
sa nouvelle obsession l'immigration qui
se veille environ à 100% francophone ou
tout près de mais encore là ce qui fait
défaut des fois dans la position de
Québec lorsqu'elle parle lorsqu'il parle
des des seuils des migration c'est
l'espèce d'absence de rationnel semble
avoir des dogmes ça peut pas être 50000
de plus et là le nouveau donne c'est que
ça doit être une immigration presque
100% 100% francophone ce qui est un
changement de vision de François Legault
parce que souvenons-nous en 2018 il
disait l'important c'est d'aller
chercher les meilleurs candidats et
ensuite on améliorera et on accélère la
francisation or là il dit non ça prend
ça absolument alors que comme Michel le
mentionne on a on a déjà pourtant
certaines mesures qui assurent que des
immigrants au moins lors d'une deuxième
génération avec des enfants qui passent
par la loi 101 qui vont à l'école en
français peuvent devenir bien intégrés
et par le bon français bref c'est ce qui
m'agace un peu dans la position de
Québec c'est qu'il y a un chiffre qui
semble être
impossible à bouger que ça semble être
couler dans le béton qui est de 50000 on
peut pas accueillir plus que ça mais en
même temps de l'autre côté on voit
augmenter en flèche le nombre
d'immigrants temporaire alors qu'on sait
que ce type d'immigration là et plus
difficile à francisé plus difficile à
régulariser donc j'ai l'impression que
on fait indirectement ce qu'on s'empêche
de faire directement c'est ce qui
accroche je trouve dans la position de
Québec rapidement sur l'immigration
qu'est-ce que souhaite monsieur Legault
à court terme en même temps je vais
juste rassé rire sur ce que Jonathan dit
en même temps dans son 50000 il y a un
petit peu plus d'ouverture qu'avant à
son seuil d'immigration de 50 000 parce
qu'encore aujourd'hui a dit c'est vrai
faut changer la recette pour mieux
francisé dans notre seuil de 50 000 par
année et si on réussit à bien changer la
recette mais peut-être qu'après ça on
pourra voir si on peut augmenter
peut-être pas de là ça se rendre à
112000 comme le dit plutôt cette semaine
juste intrudo mais ce qui veut
simplement c'est trouver toutes les
meilleures possibles d'augmenter la
proportion d'immigrants francophones et
c'est beaucoup ces solutions là qui vont
évaluer ensemble ce vendredi et un des
problèmes très concrets que va donc va
parler monsieur Legault par ailleurs
c'est le chemin Roxane je vous fais
écouter d'abord le ministre fédéral me
dit de chez nous qui dit on a presque un
accord en poche avec les Américains
c'est réglé son patron est pas d'accord
puis monsieur Legault qui en parle avec
il y a un processus de négociation
je suis très confiant que ce processus
et
est fini et maintenant c'est le
processus de ratification aux États-Unis
mais il y a beaucoup d'appui pour un
nouveau entendre
tout à fait aussi optimiste que Monsieur
mendescino on a du travail à faire on a
fait du progrès avec les Américains mais
on demeure focuser sur sur la
modernisation de l'Entente mais il reste
encore beaucoup de travail à faire
on est rendu à plus de 36000 personnes
qui sont entrées par le chemin Roxane
depuis le début de l'année seulement
puis évidemment bon oui un défi de
francisation il y a un défi aussi de
donner du service à ces personnes là
a été trop optimiste ou est-ce qu'il y a
pas dit où ça en était pas prêt à
l'annoncer comment vous avez compris ça
le principe d'optimisme peut-être un peu
de naïveté du côté de du ministre mais
destino et à l'opposé bonvois
l'expérience de Justin Trudeau qui sait
très bien que même s'il y a peut-être
pour parler qui sont avancés
faut être très très prudent avant
d'affirmer en fait même c'est le genre
de dossier ou juste dans les découpures
de presse qui vont parvenir à nos
voisins du sud de voir qu'ensemble le
vendre la peau de l'ours avant de la
route déjà ça peut ça peut nuire à des
pour parler comme cela donc je pense que
je vais être auto était prudent de
calmer le jeu ceci étant dit on peut pas
vouloir à François Legault de se tourner
vers Justin Trudeau et de dire écoutez
avant de faire des des leçons au Québec
sur nos seuils de migration sur notre
capacité peut-on au moins s'assurer de
rivaliser une situation qui est
problématique depuis plusieurs années et
qui fait en sorte que le Québec doit
casquer si on veut pour pour des fois le
manque de de rigueur du gouverneur
fédéral en cette matière là donc
là-dessus je pense François Legault un
très très bon point de dire ajouter
Trudeau peut-on régler le problème au
chemin Roxane avant de faire la leçon au
Québec sur sa capacité d'accueil réelle
et d'autant Michel que ça prend plus de
deux ans au gouvernement fédéral de
répondre à aux demandes des réfugiés qui
passent par le chemin Roxane
d'une part d'autre part ça va pas bien
dans nos relations avec les États-Unis
je vais question d'immigration en
général juste la petite chose va se
touche assez peu de gens de ce qu'on
appelle la passe Nexus qui permet à des
gens qui passent souvent la frontière
des gens d'affaires autre de passer
d'abord une voie rapide pour faire ça
les Américains veulent plus rien savoir
parce qu'il trouve que le Canada
ne fait pas les vérifications de
sécurité nécessaire alors ça c'est juste
une petite affaire qui avait été
suspendue pendant la covid qu'on veut
qu'on veut qu'on veut ramener les
Américains disent non vous faites pas ce
qu'il faut alors on n'est pas
intéressant à faire ça à imaginer je
fais un Roxane l'ensemble des tiers et
la faire très compliqué puis qui touche
même les relations internationales alors
je pose sur moi que Monsieur benissino
et rapport pour but du bon du bon café
ce matin alors ok Véronique conclusion
c'est une demande en même temps de
Québec officialiser ça comme une
vraiment une vraie porte d'entrée pour
faire en sorte que les gens en plus les
bloquer et faire rentrer là mais en même
temps François Legault a mis une
nouvelle solution ou sa ministre on
avait parlé hier c'est de dire mais
peut-être que le fédéral devrait payer
78% de la facture des services qu'on
doit offrir ces gens-là de francisation
de logements d'écoles et tout ça parce
que c'est le poids du reste du Canada
78% avec peut-être qu'à ce moment-là ils
vont voir qu'est-ce qu'on doit payer
puis peut-être qu'à ce moment-là ça va
leur prendre moins de temps justement
traiter les dossiers d'immigration donc
il y avait une pointe là de dire c'est
long ça prend deux ans les traiter ces
dossiers là pendant ce temps-là la
facture c'est Québec la paie et François
Legault ont dit moi je comprends pas
pourquoi ça prend pas plus que deux
trois mois merci à vous trois merci
beaucoup bonne soirée bonne soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI